good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
tuesday hope everyone's having an
amazing day
spring has sprung in new york and we
hope you're just living it up
it is a beautiful day it's really
feeling like it's shaping up to be a
beautiful week claude
yeah i mean um i'm like i'm really
having a hard time like my entire week
consists around my sleep schedule like i
take my sleep schedule so seriously
and i just cannot get on like a good
journey and it really affects like my
mental health and just like my physical
well-being the next day
like last night could not go to bed all
[ __ ] night the second i fall asleep
ben wakes me up why he goes theo keeps
jumping off the bed i think he has to
pay
he's like a [ __ ] take him out what
does it look like my problem and he
didn't i just like went back to sleep
but like i was just
just entering an rem cycle like and so
then like ben was like futzing with theo
the whole night like worried about him
like he was gonna die or something i'm
like he literally just had to pay
so it was just like a journey and a half
and i don't know why theo had to pee at
five in the morning cause it's like not
something he usually has to do
but he had to pee like when nature calls
she [ __ ] calls and theo answers when
nature calls
and theo said yo [ __ ] i gotta pee he
picked up the phone so
my my rem is like all off i feel like my
face looks so puffy like i am just
unwell today i'm so sorry i'm on a
journey to
um mental and physical wellness and i
invite you to join me because
i invited you last night i'm very much
considering doing a wellness retreat
good for you and i'm really excited i
think i was dreaming about the retreat
last night and i think i should do it
i like so support it just i think it's
like a little overpriced that's my only
kind of stipulation
it is and why i won't personally be
going yeah no it is overpriced like they
clearly know they can charge these
crazy prices because like people are
paying
and you're missing a few we're like we
have some vacation time coming up at the
end of the month and i think i'm going
on a retreat you guys have the best time
it's gonna be like very eat pray love i
think i should
watch that movie before i go you
definitely should have you ever watched
it no have you
no it just like looks so stupid no
totally actually speaking of
i feel like it's going to make me not
want to go 100
speaking of movies that like i should
have seen but never had yesterday i
decided to watch a movie that i can't
believe i haven't seen
um but it just like came up on netflix
i'm like it actually looks good it was
like country vibes
i watched brokeback mountain for the
first time ever and everyone was like i
remember when it came out and it was
like getting oscar buzz it was like
oh my god gay sacks like everyone's like
it was literally like the most like now
like there's so much sex on tv like
it wasn't even that crazy like you
didn't even see butt or anything like it
was
yeah totally fine but it was such a big
deal at the time it was such a big deal
at the time
and the movie was amazing honestly it
was so sad like i
didn't know that's what i was signing up
for like i was getting really choked up
at the end
star studded tell me if you knew this
anne hathaway is like a major character
in brookback mountain
no i don't think i knew that obviously
you knew jake gyllenhaal and heath
ledger and i was obviously sad to watch
heath ledger
also michelle williams i don't um maybe
i knew that i think that's where they
met and they like fell in love right
yeah it was just like a really
interesting kind of moment in history
and it's an excellent movie i highly
recommend on netflix i just
i don't know what compelled me to watch
it but i really enjoyed the journey
wow i'm so happy for you thank you i
didn't watch any tv yesterday i just got
so
booked and busy you know that's like
that happens when your stars like us
like meetings meetings
meetings meetings meetings meetings well
i also watched caught up on rupaul's
drag race and we made it down to the
final four
and it's just like redheads madness
semifinals
exactly just like just like it so i just
really feel like it's so crazy this
season has been
so good and i think for the first time
this season is a season where like my
favorites like i barely even noticed in
the beginning and like the ones that i
loved like honestly my
my girls are candy and simone and they
both made it to the finale but
if i'm just being like a good drag race
fan like i don't think
either of them really deserve to win
like definitely not candy and like
simone just disappointed me so much in
the last few weeks
when she was like so clearly the winner
from day one like i've been saying that
that's the one rihanna message like
she's been so clearly but she's just
kind of like falling off
whereas got mick and rose i literally
could not
stand rose but she's been like
acknowledging how she was like weird in
the beginning of the competition
because she didn't want anyone to say
anything bad about her and now like
she's really like coming to her own
she's so talented her and gottmick have
like been killing
every single challenge like even if they
don't win they're in the top two they
both are just like so robust they're
looks queens they're comedy queens
they're acting queens they're music
queens rosa's an amazing dancer
i think one of those two should win and
i never thought i was going to say that
because i was like a simone
writer [ __ ] die and as much as i love
candy mews like she barely made it in
the top four like she's not making it
all the way
but i don't know got maker rose like i
would be
happy with well if i've been listening
correctly you have been concerned with
simone for a while now i have right i've
been saying like every week yes rihanna
messaged her but like
she didn't she's not upheld like the
she started off strong and it's been
downhill from there and in her
confessionals like in the last episode
she
really um like bald because she's like i
don't want that to be my story like
that i fizzled out but i'm like that's
literally exactly what's happening
she made it to the top four so like she
didn't really fizzle out because it's
still like a huge accomplishment
but i know like last season like i
i love the looks queens like gigi good i
loved but she did not deserve to win
like she was just a look screen she
really didn't
do anything else um and so now i'm
really focused on finding a queen who
like checks all the boxes and gomic and
rosie like
really check all the boxes i mean if i'm
gonna make a prediction based on your
recaps like
based on what you're saying week to week
of who's like coming in strong
got mick yeah i mean got mc is
everything like first of all
she won snatch game which is such a big
deal she's also the first
um openly transgender contestant i think
on the show i remember there was one
other contestant
who came out as transgender during the
reunion i think she's the first
and that's why they've been changing a
lot of the vernacular around
like rue has like these um phrases that
he says like
at the beginning of every challenge he
always says i may the best woman
win now he says may the best drag queen
win so i think like
gomix influence is like really powerful
and she's like this
young she's just like exactly what drag
race needs like she's this young she's
just on the cover of like attitude
magazine like
the community lives for her like i do
think gottmake is gonna win i think so
too
and i like live for comic when are the
finals i don't know
i think they do like like a special and
then
got it i forget but usually it's live
like in a ballroom in la and like it's
filled with like drag race fans and
celebrities like miley cyrus went one
year like
but they obviously can't do that and
last year it was peak
quarantine and they like filmed it at
home on zoom and it was
pathetic like [ __ ] pathetic like the
worst
but it was also the beginning of
quarantine like they didn't know
yeah hopefully this year they can do it
like i don't know maybe at the drag race
studio
like yeah yeah something crazy there's
no fans no fans but it's
it usually is the best night of the year
because like they all lip-sync for their
lives
so hopefully like they make it a
production because last year was just
completely unacceptable but it was
extenuating circumstances of course
of course okay i'm excited for you but
speaking of the finals red has
redhead madness finals are today the
polls are still open for the semi-finals
but it does look like it's coming down
to
before we were strangers versus girl
with no job no way
oh my god this is someone expected like
it's a counter i checked the polls
yesterday and i didn't want to keep
checking because like i just didn't want
to like
i was very tempted to obviously like
influence the polls like with my
instagram
um but i didn't and i checked and it was
like 40 50 like it was just started so
like i wasn't
wow i just want to i want to thank the
redheads first of all for believing in
me the the redheads host
and i want to thank the redheads
community for really you know as a
first-time author just like opening up
to me
and just accepting me for the author
that i am i'm like literally getting
choked up like i think i'm gonna cry
no like this competition has been fierce
fierce twists and turns at every round
and may the best book win
burns well i don't want to like now say
it and have like people go and like vote
against me no i mean
like you guys it's we need to protect
the integrity of redheads madness
100 so stay voting if you have read
these books
and i do think it's a sign that you
should read before we were strangers
because it's obviously like
really popular quality okay that that's
my next book i haven't even had one up
on cue yet
sweet fabulous oh also an update from
yesterday's show
i have been you know i stand corrected
and i'm not
too you know big of a woman in more of a
literal sense because i'm obviously
physically a big woman but
i'm not too big of a person to admit
that i was wrong
and i was super wrong about the
historical
journey journey that jackie's on i
thought people would not be interested
in
but the feedback is fierce and i listen
to the feedback and feedback says no no
we live for the historical journey and
dance moms like get you a girl
who could do both they said we live for
the historical journey
take us on it and they also said jackie
you will love dance moms so i know
you're like really hesitant
i will get it but commented on our
instagram yesterday like i don't know
how you can disrespect
the name of jill vertex i wouldn't dream
of it
and i'm telling you i will watch dance
moms when it is my time
i understand today is not my time but
the time will come i promise you okay
for when i'm just like looking for some
light-hearted dancy fair and i know you
didn't even like
mean to but you like dressed like a
dance moms contestant today
with the low bud and like the athleisure
maybe not the louis vuitton boots but
yeah no like it's a very athleisure look
because i wanted to wear this sweater
i like it um and so you just need to
like dress around the sweater and also
it's like i'm on my last day of hair
before i need to wash it
same so it was a low bun which i haven't
done in so long because i've been like
living for
doing my hair like with my dyson um but
today i was like
[ __ ] it my dyson's been acting up i
think it needed a few days off
i like one of my biggest regrets in life
i always say you know there's three
stories i always share dennis's funeral
um turkey baster turkey baster
and i think i have my new one because
one of my biggest regrets is obviously
not getting in that police
car oh of course everyone knows that
story one of the three going to be
bumped
from the rapid from the road that's my
third oh okay um but you said you have a
new one
yeah but it's really not that big of a
deal but my biggest regret like dead ass
is
purchasing a dyson air app like i think
i'm probably one of the only people who
thinks it's like an actual piece of [ __ ]
and even if it works the way that it did
and it cost 200
it's still too expensive so the fact
that they're out here having the
audacity nerve and gall
to charge people six hundred dollars
it's crazy it's so stupid and i've used
it four times so
i would have said completely agree up
until
two months ago you guys have probably
like noticed the day i learned how to
use my dyson
um and now that i've learned how to do
it it's made the biggest difference
i know how to do it like i watched
videos i i thought i knew
and you need to like i found the one
thing that like just makes my hair
look like i got it blown out or that i
was capable of doing a round brush
myself and
and for me who's not capable of doing
that either
it is now worth it but you have to find
you have to make the dyson you have to
listen to your dyson and make it work
for you
i know but it's like i paid 600 like i
don't need to listen to you
i know but you need to take the time to
curate like the experience
i'd rather just go to dry bar really i
find that to be
the most painful thing you could do to
yourself 100 i haven't been to a dry bar
in like four years i'm so glad like
you know as a society especially in new
york like we came to the conclusion like
dry bar is terrible and a waste of money
and like we've all kind of moved past
that phase of our lives guaranteed to
hurt your feelings in some way or
another yeah or like physically hurt you
like pulling your hair
so hard or like leave um
purple shampoo residue on your forehead
when you're not even a blonde
what did that happen to you i came home
after like my ugly ass blowout
and i looked in the mirror and there was
like purple on my forehead which is what
they use
for um to like preserve the color i'm
like
i don't have dye in my hair i'm not even
blonde
what is the reason for the purple
shampoo what was the reason i have no
idea they wound up like giving me a free
blowout but it's like oh great now i
have to go back actually one
three cookies the one good thing about
dry bar was those little sugar cookies
they had at the front but now because of
kobe they probably don't have that
yeah so it's like the one good thing or
maybe they're more now like individually
wrapped or something
yeah yeah no i'm so glad we're over that
phase but um
we digress the dyson air wrap yeah
dennis's funeral
turkey baster
like those three they didn't just one
day we decided i know it was a natural
progression of things
so many things bring you back to that
story yes
and i had not heard your dyson story i
saw it on your your instagram once but
that is not a pattern maybe no but
that's like my like classic unpopular
opinion
like i literally [ __ ] hate this okay
but i think that's a different category
than
stories that you can't help but no but
i'm just letting you know like i'm going
to be bringing it up a lot
like just to kind of prove like i'm so
that's like this quirky girl who like
does different opinions than other
people
yeah you're just like contrary yeah i'm
just like so crazy you're just
different from other girls honestly i'm
not like other girls
like at all like you know beer bro and
like i'm just
i don't know i just prefer to hang out
with dudes like i'm a guy's girl you
know i don't think people think you're
like other girls
i just want you to know that no no if i
was like anyone else like the world
would it would be so fabulous no it
would not be able to handle like the
torture that is made like
i'm truly one of a kind yeah we all are
i think we're all one-of-a-kind oh my
god that victoria justice clip like will
literally lives and lives in my head run
free no anytime i use the word all
i'm victoria justice yeah i mean i think
we all sing a lot
and anytime i use the phrase for me but
not
for me or if i'm referencing you know
the ambulance industry
call an ambulance call an ambulance but
not
for me um so we have a great show for
you guys today
no tv recap because thankfully the
bachelor wasn't on
last night um but tonight we have real
housewives of dallas and then we have
kardashians and there's a lot of to keep
up with in the news this week
especially the cardassian drama of it
all
we have kardashians tonight no no
kardashian news today oh yes we have a
lot
to discuss and so i think without a
further ado
where are you
what song am i singing when i sing that
where are you is that scooby-doo you run
something dead and left it
what are the lyrics feel me do we
where are you you are so annoying like
what is it i've never watched scooby-doo
i never know him i'm sorry to this man
and honestly like
thelma looks annoying i said it i
[ __ ] said it oh i think she's styling
livin up in the city okay did we have it
nope we haven't crunched yet
without further due
[Laughter]
without further ado
here are the fast side stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is frame bridge
sponsored by frame bridge excuse me
and i got a lot of messages asking like
what was the company with the frames
pay attention please in the words of
teresa giudice
frame bridge makes it easier and more
affordable than ever to frame your
favorite things without ever leaving
your house
you can add a gallery wall to your home
office or send the perfect gift
from art prints and diplomas to the
photos sitting in your phone
you can frame bridge just about anything
here's how it works
go to framebridge.com and upload your
photo or they'll send you a package to
safely mail in your physical pieces
you can preview your item in dozens of
frame styles and gallery wall
layouts choose your favor to get free
recommendations from their talented
designers
the experts at frame bridge will custom
frame your item and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door
ready to hang instead of the hundreds
you'd pay at a framing store their
prices start 39
and all shipping is free plus our
listeners will get 15 off their first
order at framebridge.com
when they use promo code toast so again
if you want to get 15 off
go to framebridge.com the promo code is
toast
it is the fastest best most efficient
way revolutionizing the framing industry
it's so easy it's so affordable
and it comes in such good quality you
had amazing
designs and if like you're looking to do
a gallery while i'm like you have no
idea where to start like frame bridge
will just do it for you
which is the best thing ever you don't
have to spend like hours on pinterest
measuring out your wall
framebridge.com promo code toast
thank you for that claudia such a great
company such a great company
okay first story even though we've known
that kim kardashian is a billionaire
forbes has decided that they too agree
that kim kardashian is officially a
billionaire okay
forbes is like that ex-boyfriend who
like pretends he doesn't like you but
then like always comes back no it's like
pretends he's not like following you on
instagram
but it's like there like the
acknowledgement they should like after
the disgrace that they did
like not only with the kylie thing they
like are embarrassed that they called to
the first self-made billionaire
then they got [ __ ] from making kim a
billionaire when she like wasn't or
whatever like
all these kind of mishaps when it comes
to the kardashians like going into their
tax reports and saying that they lie
about all their money like they need to
never mention the kardashians again no i
know and i feel like we reported a few
months ago that kim was officially a
billionaire not from forbes but from
other
bloomberg veritable financial sources
and now
forbes has decided that she is a
billionaire which we knew
but we've been knowing so she must be
like a super billionaire if forbes has
to come to the table no honestly i'm
i'm embarrassed for forbes i'm like so
embarrassed for forbes
aren't you embarrassed like to be so
messy when it comes to the kardashians
finances like getting in fights with
them on twitter and stuff like
forbes is like really in the last year
especially like
when it comes to the kardashians but now
overall like i take their word just like
so much less seriously
ever since that and i found out that
like they actually don't choose forbes
under 30 like people have to apply
yes i totally agree and also a little
more kim business news is that she is
getting into skin care
yes she filed a slew of applications to
trademark the name
skin by kim on march 30th according to
documents
i love that name yes but it's skkn
skin by kim i don't know i'm always very
cautious of you know putting lots of
caves together you know
i just think it's not a good like road
to go down
but we have to learn from history and
i'm just i'm afraid kim is not learning
like i get it like
kim kardashian i guess that's also a big
sign because if
that means she's like probably changing
her name because it would have had to be
squinned by kim if she was still kim
kardashian west
but why couldn't it just be skin no i
don't know maybe she couldn't get that
trademarked i don't know
i don't know but judging by the filing
it will have skin care hair care nail
products perfumes
candles and more okay she already has
candles and she has perfume so i wonder
if they'll fall
under if kkw fragrance will now fall
under
skin by kim i mean that would make more
sense because i don't think the
fragrance
industry is like that big where she
needs her own company kkw fragrances
like the fragrances can fall under like
kkw beauty even
and i wonder if this is just a rebrand
from kkw
because she's no longer kkw oh my god
that's such a good call
and so the kkk in skin right he's like
to emphasize that she's
kk now and she's dropped the w a very
interesting idea
but did it say that they're going to be
selling beauty products skin care
yeah oh i guess makeup palettes yeah so
will kkw beauty say kkw beauty then
maybe
skin covers every other category and
then maybe like once
skin picks up merch merge
oh yeah merge joggers
merge maybe once skin picks up then
the beauty comes underneath they merge
yeah and then they could sell merch
um yeah this is you know
do we need another brand no do we
support
and purchase yes we do so and do we
continually follow the various business
ventures of the kardashian women
yes yeah i mean it does feel like in a
certain way for the kardashians at least
like the
beauty space is like oversaturated for
them and i feel like
why skims is like so successful and i
don't know what for sure but skims has
to be more successful than kkw beauty
um and that's because it's like a it's
an untapped market within the kardashian
empire so like
this is just like for me like and they
also say kris jenner's starting a
skincare line which is obviously
different
um it's just like a lot like maybe like
create like something like totally new
and random like i don't know like
kids toys like something stupid i would
say i'm sure it feels like to us like
it's a lot but
if the sales are there why wouldn't they
keep if it ain't broke don't fix it
why not keep up with demand if the sales
are there
if the sales were there yeah but so i'm
assuming since they keep
putting out new beauty stuff the sales
are there well i think for kylie like
kylie skin
and kylie cosmetics are like booming
staples what's so crazy is when she
launched kylie's skin i was like oh this
feels like excessive but sure whatever
it's different
and now it's like i feel like kylie skin
is so big and necessary and i think the
way they launch it like the branding is
perfect like it's so gen z it's so cute
i feel like soon it could eclipse
kylie cosmetics like i feel like now i
just feel like
based on my perception if i were the
next kylie product i'll probably buy
will probably be skin and not cosmetics
i haven't really bought kylie cosmetics
in a while like i support and love and i
i just like it's not my type of makeup
it's like instagram makeup which is
which is why it's so popular
but i go for like a more you know
natural dewy look yeah i'm actually
wearing um
kylie on my lips today is my favorite
color
yeah so this is interesting what was the
first kim story oh the billy billionaire
happy for her congrats on all your
success like
who are you dating next like that's
where my head is kind of at you know i'm
like
so happy for kravis that i think like we
need kim to have that
yeah but but kravis was an unexpected
choice for courtney
i think and so i just i don't even want
to start thinking about who i want him
to be because i just wanted to be
someone
i wouldn't think yeah well because kim
obviously has a type like
football players rappers like that is
her type so maybe it's time for her to
step out of her box you know
maybe a businessman beau or a baseball
player i don't know like she's something
new
i think well she did date a baseball
player who um i think his name was
austin
miles austin plays football no no
she dated a baseball player miles austin
hold on
baseball players like truly make the
most money and i think football wide
receiver
fine miles austin right yeah yeah he was
hot yeah yeah
kim i don't think she ever dated a
baseball player yeah that doesn't like
sound like something i think a
businessman beau
no of course i mean look at her she's
literally a businessman
what's the female bow [ __ ]
no excuse me but okay also thank you for
bringing that up
i am reclaiming the word [ __ ] i can't
deal with all these people getting
offended like who's getting offended
okay like literally a few years ago this
is like i have the journey i've been on
like two years ago i got into a fight
with olivia
at the regency hotel do you remember we
were having like lunch
and i called her [ __ ] and like we were
like like we were like in like a fake
fight but when i was like [ __ ] it like
escalated it to a real fight when like i
was like still joking
and i obviously had to apologize for
calling her a [ __ ] but like i didn't
call her a [ __ ] i called her [ __ ]
which is so [ __ ] different
and i would just like to reclaim the
word as like like a sister type of
okay well if i may if i may interject
here
i was there i'm remembering it it's not
as if you use like you call everyone
[ __ ] all the time
you guys were having words and then you
threw in the word [ __ ] so like sure you
decided that you meant it in an
endearing way
but oh my god my blood is literally
boiling because that's just like
not what happened and like it was it was
like literally a joke until olivia made
it like
not a joke okay i'm just saying like
context is key you know i'm just saying
like female to female like [ __ ] is like
a great word like i think that we should
kind of reclaim it of course like
a man calling a woman a [ __ ] is never
acceptable that's not what i'm talking
about i'm just saying like
like if kim's like like a business
businesswoman [ __ ] like
you know like i think that's fine really
you okay i'm that's fine i i have no
issue with the word [ __ ] but like you
really think the phrase like
businesswoman [ __ ] is like something
that you would like no it doesn't even
work but you know what i mean i'm just
saying like
hypothetically you literally can't even
like you would hate
like if i call if i say like about
that's like boss [ __ ] like
oh no i just don't think business woman
[ __ ] is like the right phrase that's
not the word i'm look that's not like
what i mean here what i mean is just
like
the word [ __ ] is ours for the taking
and like i have already started the
journey and i encourage
everyone to come along with me okay that
i'm totally here for thank you
and i'm just gonna leave it there i'm
gonna leave it there
and it's there goodbye good day sir
are you ready for our next story sure
kardashian team is working hard to
remove an unwanted
photo of chloe from the internet this is
twisted
this is team kardashian is going into
overdrive to erase a private photo
showing a side of chloe few outside of
the family get to see
the image shows the reality star's face
and body as she appears in a bikini by a
pool without
what what page six thinks is the heavy
editing and airbrushing
that our mainstays of photos kardashian
normally puts on instagram
the shot which page six has confirmed
its authentic soon spread around the
internet
but many copies of the photo were taken
down under legal threats from the
kardashian camp
which called the image beautiful but
said they wanted it gone because it was
unauthorized
the tracy romulus who's the chief
marketing officer for kkw brand said the
color edited photo was taken of chloe
during a private family gathering and
posted to social media without
permission by mistake
by an assistant chloe looks beautiful
but it is it is
it is within the right of the copyright
owner to not want an image
not intended to be published taken down
okay so before we dive into this um they
say was this an assistant
my sources are saying it was mj and does
mj have instagram
can we before we do anything just like
have a moment of silence
for mj because after this you know
fiasco
she cause i don't think she'll be
invited to easter ever again i disagree
so let's just take a moment of silence
i think mj will be fine i think that
this was 100 mj like i could still see
this happening
she doesn't understand she thinks
chloe's beautiful like she puts up the
picture
um no a lot of people are really like
from this
scenario because it really highlights
like how all of chloe's other pictures
are so edited they're comparing them to
other bikini photos
um and especially her face because she
looks like a teenager in the photo like
she actually looks like the way she used
to look on like season one of the
kardashians like 15 years ago
so people are getting really bent out of
shape and like what does this mean you
know like what are we
what message are they sending and i have
really tried
very hard to find a [ __ ] to give in my
soul
and i do not have one [ __ ] to give like
i
i want to care like about what this says
for the beauty standard i i do
but i just don't i i guess people are
upset that like this is
what like i don't this story's like
makes me sad like
this picture i think she looks so great
and
it's clear and i mean you see all these
like instagram pictures where people
show how like with the right lighting
and the right angle like you can
literally look like a different person
i think she's backlit here like no one
would ever post a picture no one
kardashian or otherwise would ever post
a picture with this sort of lighting
because it's just not
splattering but also it's like yes
sometimes chloe's pictures she
definitely uses
an app that puts a little more makeup on
her face whatever it is
but we see her every week on the show
and even if
like in her confessionals i don't think
that they have video filters that they
put on the girls
and then we see her like in the spartan
race like we see her from every [ __ ]
angle like we've seen her we know what
she looks like
sure she looks a little different in her
instagram pictures who the [ __ ] doesn't
i just don't think that this is people
like are making this such a big deal in
general not just this picture
like chloe's changing face but we see
her we see what you look like like
it's not that crazy to me yeah no and
like i just
personally don't care like okay you
wanna
inject your face live your life you want
to uh
look like a different person in your
photos live your life like i've never
been the type of person to like
jump on the train of being like she has
a new face like yeah get your own face
like i
really don't care like live your life
but like what makes you happy do what
you got to do protect yourself
people are so mean out there like oh i
wonder why we're all photoshopping our
photos so have you ever read some of the
instagram comments on like a natural
photo
yeah we're all like shocked like
everyone's face tuning we live in
literally the meanest country in the
world like
of course she is i just feel like we
know what she
like we see every facet of what she
looks like so
no to me the most shocking thing about
this is that chloe looks like that
because that looks like literally a
picture from 2009. yeah it's like she's
changed so much but she's exactly the
same
yeah so it's like you guys think she
changed her whole [ __ ] face like
right so which is it now right now
yeah right did she change our whole face
or not i know this is probably just an
unpopular opinion but like i just
i can't seem to care like about the like
the message of it all cause people
are like really bent out of shape that
like this is just like indicative of
like how much you edit their photos and
how they
influence the beauty standard and it's
like don't judge someone like until you
know what it's like to be them like
i'm sure it's impossible to like be
churning out these thirsty photos like
your entire business depends on it like
every time you do like
people are commenting on the size of
your ass the size of your thighs the
size of your arms the size of your neck
the size of your chin
she was like if this is what she has to
do to protect her self-worth like i i
can't be bothered to give a [ __ ]
i agree with you but that's not like my
initial thought my initial thought is
like we know what these girls look like
they
they show us all the time so even if in
one picture it's a little bit different
like
they post videos they're on tv like we
see them from every single angle we know
what they look like they can't hide they
literally
can't they write they go on like talk
shows yeah that's fair they're filmed
from every angle on their show like
if you want to know what they look like
it's there for you they're not hiding
yeah
but the things that they can control in
the pictures that they do post they're
putting their best foot forward like all
of us
but i do think that their like attempt
to scrub it from the internet and made
people
more obsessed with the photos like that
was their name i never saw this photo
until you told me that this was a story
yeah no i didn't see the photo and then
i saw the headlines and then i'm like
let me go find what photo they're
talking about and i found it on reddit
like
i think that always it's always the
cover-up not the crime you know
yes and i think that is true here
speaking of crimes
bravo will continue to film gen shaw's
legal drama
after fraud arrests as they should i
disagree
jen shaw may be facing prison but her
real housewives of salt lake city drama
is not going anywhere soon
the powers that be at bravo are planning
to make the federal fraud and money
laundering charges she faces a central
part of the reality show's second season
including exclusive footage of the
embattled business woman's arrest a
source told page six
bravo knows full well that viewers are
following every detail of this case and
will continue to do so as it progresses
so producers plan to follow it just as
closely and use whatever footage they
legally can
so far they have filmed the lead-up an
aftermath of jen's arrest as well as her
co-star's reactions of course
um source says it's rare that bravo has
a big hit like salt lake city on his
hands right out of the gate
and the team hoped to continue that
momentum when production for season two
began
now with the news of gen zorres they are
sure to have even more success than they
imagined yeah especially since jen hopes
to continue
shooting if bravo and her lawyers allow
it she can only say so much however as
it remains an ongoing case uh i can just
imagine
i hate that i can i can't say i can't
speak yeah i mean obviously
this is like a golden egg in the hand of
bravo like
salt lake city was an amazing first
season people really enjoyed it and this
gen shopping is the biggest thing to
ever happen to the housewives franchise
like since teresa going to jail like
it's literally so big
so of course they're going to use the
opportunity there is like an ethics
question here it's like
why do we give a platform to someone who
literally like abused
her business and took advantage of
advantage of elderly people vulnerable
people and stole from them yeah
so it is like an ethical question but i
think at the end of the day like bravo
cares about one thing and one thing only
and that's ratings and like this is
going to be like
probably one of the highest rated
seasons in housewife's history
i understand that they obviously are not
going to drop the golden egg
that they have in this storyline but um
and maybe
we'll see how it it plays out this is
one insider speaking to page six so you
so you never know what the plan is but
andy did break his silence yeah on radio
andy and said oy vey hoping and praying
that none of it is true
and that is true that this has to go to
trial and kill
innocent child proven guilty yes but
i just think but she did it yeah it's
like it's a federal like
investigation and so now it
whatever i just i hope that they follow
the story line but
at what point do we stop like making
glamorizing crimes and criminals right
giving them a platform and
yeah no it's it's an it's we're at a
fork in the road
as housewives stands like this is a true
question of moral and ethics
mm-hmm and i don't know where we go from
here and hasn't been shy in firing
people
for ethical reasons for ethical reasons
people cross lines and they get fired
and dorinda
turkey based uh i have been a proponent
of that like i really have even with
people i like like i loved phaedra but
like
she [ __ ] up like big time and i am a
supporter of
the end deserve to be fired 100 i'm a
supporter of bravo kind of
drawing a line in the sand at some point
and i feel like jen shaw like
was beyond the line like 35 years ago
like 100
but with this latest slew of crimes
she's beyond the line one thousand
percent in the words of joey tribriotti
she can't even see the line the line is
just a dot to her
right but can bravo still see the line
like i know it's but see
they're struggling with the same thing
like ethics versus ratings and at the
end of the day like bravo only cares
about money and ratings and this is
a golden opportunity i don't i mean i
understand that that's
true like generally how businesses
operate money in ratings but there is
also like a
compliance like hr yeah you know i don't
and if it was just money and ratings it
might not keep phaedra like that
right right yeah was a huge thing
no it's it's an interesting point i'm
very curious to see
where it goes and like what the
conversations being had around it are
because right now it's like so
sensationalized like
no one's even realizing like that you
are in a way like glamorizing this
crime um but people are just so obsessed
with knowing what happened like they of
course want to see it on their
televisions yes but i think there's a
way that we can
follow the storyline through the
reactions of the women without
giving gensha a platform any longer yeah
yeah i don't know so we
will have to see wait and see what
happens and they better speed the season
the [ __ ] up
yeah like get us the footage no yeah
like prioritize
everyone drop what you're doing get more
cameramen
yeah start women yeah are you ready for
our next story it's a little big movie
news
little bmn bmn godzilla vs kong opens to
48 and a half million dollars at
domestic box office
the biggest weekend of covet era
everyone's talking about godzilla versus
kong having the team
no that's crazy because 48 million like
would not have been a lot before koben
yeah but i think you can also watch it
at home
it debuted on hbo max because zach
watched it over the weekend i did not
join him no um but he said was really
good and everyone's talking about it so
it's like the big
box office of the moment but it's the
first in a while
yeah right um i don't know anything
about this movie like who's in it
okay that i don't know who plays
godzilla
and what about king kong i don't know um
okay well happy for the movie theater
industry actually okay
the film stars thank you alexander
skarsgard
love of my life millie bobby brown
rebecca hall brian tyree henry
oguri asa gonzalez love her julian
dennison
lance reddick jessica henwick kyle
chandler
love of my lifetimes too um demian
beshear
and newcomer kaylee hoddle i haven't
heard of a lot of those people but happy
for them that like their first big movie
is like this
blockbuster sensation i totally agree no
i did not even know that there was a new
movie coming out like
that's how like in my own world i've
been yeah
yeah and also but like we're not huge on
the action movies
no we ain't it's big news oh also you
want to hear something like kind of
crazy
sure so have you heard of this well you
know this already but just for the sake
of the podcast pretend like you're not
have you heard of bitcloud no
tell me more i actually don't really
know what it is i actually don't know
i've heard of it i don't know what it is
it's like a social media platform where
like followers are like bitcoin currency
and like you can like make money i have
no idea like elon musk is on it there's
like a lot of legit people on it
and someone has been impersonating me on
there like making money as me and
literally like i got so many dm's
yesterday from people
being like is this you on big cloud like
how can i follow you and i'm like i'll
and the person you can like tweet it
looks like twitter so you can like post
like
status updates status updates and this
person like um
is obviously not me because they're not
funny at all like their first joke was
like am i a millionaire now
like i would never say that like that's
not funny you'd say billionaire
right um so just
psa if you're on big clout like that
ain't me i wonder who it is
i know that's what i want to figure out
too like what loser is spending their
time
like if you're going to impersonate
someone like impersonate someone
actually famously recognizable so you
could like
actually make money but maybe i'm just
like the perfect level of like z-list to
go
like under the radar yeah but then i saw
the person trying to get verified
so that could be like really sticky you
could have an identity crisis on your
hands no i know so like if anyone here
like works at big cloud like i don't
even know what that is like
please help me like and also like maybe
i want to join big cloud and they have
my username
over their profile take the followers
they literally have my they stole my bio
from
instagram and they uploaded the picture
of my book cover as
maybe it's you maybe you did it when you
were drunk
no i don't think so but like it's
definitely possible
think about it it's definitely like in
the realm of possibility i like if
you've
been at a party everybody's like talking
about big cloud and you're like hey i
should get on it
and then you're like tweeting am i a
millionaire now hello
it's a good theory but even in my most
drunken state i would never make that
dumb joke like pharrell
okay okay so that's like that's how i
know it really wasn't me but that was a
good
interesting little little journey we
went on
okay fifth and final story something
that i saw really is upsetting you one
of the web's pioneers
yahoo answers i'm upset will be wiped
from the internet in may
yahoo answers a question and answer
platform that launched more than 15
years ago and became
one of the largest troves of information
and misinformation
on the internet is shutting down on may
4th
here's the thing i feel conflicted for a
multitude of reasons
when i think of yahoo answers i think of
nostalgia i think like of literally like
googling my homework answers and like
every now and then like yahoo answers
like literally explained it perfectly
and like it
it saved lives like it got me into
college like for i will that
for that i will always be grateful but
it's
important lest we not forget that yahoo
is the company that
literally canceled our show and ruined
our lives and like literally is the
worst place on earth so
bye peace out
but no in all seriousness like yahoo
answers was a safe haven for a lot of us
at a young age and it's upsetting my
affinity towards yahoo answers was
knowing that there was someone out there
asking the exact same question as me
relatable yes you know yeah so whether
you're looking for advice or just like a
tactical response like you're not
someone else you know it's it's that
feeling of
universality and community and relation
community community universality
relations in communities a hundred
percent
yeah so like that is so that's i'll miss
that like yeah like
you know you were crazy for like asking
this random question like no actually 30
000 people have also asked it yeah and
others are answering and people are
liking it and like you're not alone
yeah and i guess there is a new forum
like it's called
quora q-u-o-r-a that has like kind of
replaced yahoo answers they come up
first in seo like when i search random
questions
so it's not like we're completely lost
but
i just wanted to kind of pay homage to a
community that really served me at my
most vulnerable
in high school yeah and also i feel like
now it's like if you have a question
like there's a facebook group for that
oh a hundred percent yeah they'll talk
to you but there is a facebook
you might get the answer you were
looking for worth it
well those are the five stories and i
feel as though you needed to know them
and i'm so excited because for the first
time in a while we've got a little
kelly's mindless news like the 4th of
july oh my god i had no idea well we
didn't have a tv recap segment today and
i wanted to
so long i know and this is kind of
breaking news
um kelly ripa makes a revelation about
her daughter lola
and it's so relatable now i just want to
make it clear
we are in no way mocking we need to have
like a disclaimer like
we are not mocking kelly ripo we're
ready for some city aries companies or
party members no we have nothing but
respect for kelly right but sometimes
your news can be mindless yes
yes wait we need to record it on the
sound board
oh my god that is good do it again okay
we want you to know that this has no
bearing on kelly's family businesses or
any of her subsidiaries we have nothing
but respect for kelly rip and her family
but sometimes her news can be mindless
so good we'll we'll perfect it
afterwards okay
kelly ripa enjoyed some quality time off
work during spring break
spending it with her husband mark
consuelos and their three children the
live with kelly and ryan starr's kids
have grown up in the public eye
matt and have appeared on the abc
morning on her instagram
yeah like they're not being hounded by
paparazzi and i'm sure they live a very
normal life
except for the fact that they're like
super rich but live with kelly and ryan
stars kids have grown up in the public
eye and have appeared on the abc morning
show over the years
but now that they are older they prefer
to stay out of the spotlight especially
her daughter lola so why are you writing
an article about her
but here we go putting her in the
spotlight the doting mum wanted to mark
her family's easter is it the sun
yeah no it's um hello magazine the
number one um offender in
kelly kelly my unless news the joding
mum wanted to mark her family's easter
celebrations on social media on sunday
but told her instagram followers that
she's sharing a throwback picture of her
kids instead
as it was the photo that lola had
approved this is so mindless i actually
can't even follow it
in the picture lola and her brothers
michael and joaquin were posing joaquin
sorry lola and her brothers michael and
joaquin
were posing in the kitchen at their
family home in new york surrounded by
extravagant chocolate eggs they
literally look like the ones everyone
has from like two maid
fans were quick to react to the post
with one writing i love how prescriptive
lola is
i love how prescriptive lola is she's
probably going to run a large
corporation one day
while another wrote my 14 year old
daughter is exactly the same i can't
post anything without her approval
a third added thank you lola for
approving super cute
lola isn't the only one who prefers to
keep a low profile in an interview with
glamour magazine recently kelly opened
up about her son michael's desire to
stay out of the spotlight when he was
younger
she said i was not allowed to discuss
anything i couldn't talk about his life
his grades even though they were great
i couldn't talk about school i wasn't
allowed to show his prom pictures on tv
what even though i may have as long as i
got the girl's permission from her
parents
but like still like highly inappropriate
the donating parent added that she would
never discuss any of her children
without their permission that's good
mark and kelly and mark are doting
parents to three children it would be
very unfair to use my bullhorn to
discuss somebody that did not want to be
discussed
i'm very mindful of that being the
boundary i feel like so this is kelly's
mindful news
that kind of seems like a direct
response to us
wow the use of that word kelly and
mindful
never thought i'd see him together never
thought i'd see it but i think the
takeaway here is that
it's really speechless so like what is
the takeaway
like what did i just read so it like
hurts kids so when we talked about here
we go talk about them letting you know
we're not going to talk about that right
but we're going to talk about them and
exploit them
just let you know that we're not talking
about them got it well thank you for
keeping up with kelly's mindless
news like the 4th of july um
that's our show it is our show don't
don't turn it off yet because you never
know something might come to us
i'm done i guess i'm done too but we
actually are not done because you are
coming over later because we
got our krispy kreme delivery it is here
thank you mike tattersfield and the
whole cream family we got
glazed and they happened to maybe see
yesterday's episode because we got the
oreo that we discussed yesterday
the fact that they sent the oreo means
they didn't see you yesterday no
or they're so good they know we're going
to love them like
we just judged a book by its cover
interesting i mean it was their photo
that they put out and they made it look
bad
but and if you want to see the photo it
is on our instagram please share your
thoughts and like if
if this wets your whistle so jackie and
i are going to be filming a patreon
mukbang
for the patreon channel it will be a
feast of the oreo donuts the glazed
donuts and
we got in the mail today a pie the tall
house cookie pie we were raving about
last week
from beverly hills beverly hills cafe
the last remaining location in miami
lakes thank you to the former employee
slash toaster who like literally stole
one and gave it to us we appreciate you
doing lawyers work
and i on the one hand like i'm so
excited on the other hand
like this is it has a really tall task
to live up to
of being like our favorite dessert like
what if what if it's gross yeah like we
were kids
you thought anything was good if we
don't like it we could always blame on
the fact that it was shipped
we also need to purchase some vanilla
ice cream did you have any
no but i could definitely get some for
this okay i can pick it up also okay
maybe we'll both
we all i think we can all pick up some
ice cream
um so yeah be sure to look out for that
patreon.com morning toast
our subscription service this show is
completely free always will be
we'll say i'm kidding um but if you want
more episodes from us
if you pay 7.99 per month on our patreon
channel you get five extra episodes from
jackie and i
they are vlogs they are podcast episodes
they're always a little bit more in
depth a little bit more behind the
scenes a little bit more salacious
because we're behind the paywall
7.99 great content great way to support
your gals patreon.com morning toast and
then you get access to the toast after
which is a wonderful facebook group but
also you can then make suggestions for
episodes if there's something you want
from us a question you can join the
general q a ask a question and it's
honestly
the best thing after yahoo answers it's
so true
it is it is so true thank you are you
done
yeah now i'm done now oh but don't
forget to vote in the finals for
redheads madness going down today it's
gonna be
crazy and while you're at it like pick
up a copy of my book girl no job the
crazy beautiful life of an instagram
there's monster even though
the numbers are in and like the books
are the book sales are shook like i
don't even need to promote it like
that's how fabulous
the toasters are we'd love to see it
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast fast
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so spotify itunes stitch or public
radio ihot radio cast box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you have
an amazing day we'll see you tomorrow
for
hump day goodbye